human actions are destroying habitats  decimating our entire ecosystem and  disrupting the circle of life under the  rise in drought cases it is up to us to  be guardians of our own natural world  save our wild species and provide a home  [Laughter]  it is said charity begins at home and  for this young orphaned elephants this  charitable Foundation is what they call  home it is the place where they discover  and are taught life's lessons experience  love and grapple with loss and even for  millions of other species home hangs in  the balance human actions are destroying  habitats decimating our entire ecosystem  and disrupting the circle of life under  the rise in drought cases it is up to us  to be guardians of our own natural world  save our wild species and provide a home  foreign